I want to call this chapter the one
variable that allows somebody to crush
it mom doesn't come around nice like a
visible and I see with clarity listen
like my name is Gary Saba [ __ ]
I've been telling you it's all about
I'll triple a camera credit research the
meaning of pleasure my specialty putting
the word hahaha there he is
yo how you doing that's good
I mean I s s going to ubers headquarters
and then I'm flying to LA and taking a
red-eye to Miami okay good all right so
I'll see you I'll see you tomorrow I'll
hook you up have a good session all
right but the early days the early days
of building anything so quick shoutout
to everybody who left the comment thank
you for educating me it's the fourth
wall d-roc not the third wall both lungs
I'm breaking makes a lot more sense
actually that's the fourth one I was
like you were wrong that
you were right he was right right
Oh God
what wasn't a feature feature I'll bet
well I'm to rock I don't know why you're
creeping up on my [ __ ] but yeah what's a
lot I do really nondescript tweets I
don't I haven't done a long time we have
to go back to my 2009 10 11 stuff so
basically once in a while little things
that I put out that I want to recall 7
or 8 years from now I think I think what
I've been able to understand through the
years is consumer behavior what people
responding what they care about
I think I'm on the verge of like doing
some interesting stuff a lot of
different genres and I think about it
like hacking culture right I think about
you know you know what's emerging
culture and how do you infiltrate it and
bring it more value I use the word hack
as a positive you know I think that a
lot of the Silicon Valley hack culture
has created some of the greatest
products in the world whether it's to
leave our facebook an Airbnb Google
going back you know so yeah
I tweet stuff sometimes about when we
look back at so I think being in Silicon
Valley right now put me in the mood of
that half term and
which one of em in viola mean it was
rather go up the first one that third
one that one and the third one
especially wanted their get naked the
thing is its assistant look a lot of
things have changed since I wrote crush
it up mainly the fact that when I wrote
it nobody knew what the hell I was
really talking about and now it's
established in our society that you know
that if you are the foremost expert in
you know alpha TV show that the social
networks of the world have become so big
that it's not just YouTube anymore that
you've got all these different platforms
that allow you to amass an audience and
you can make a living I mean the amount
of people that are making six figures a
year on Instagram is baffling to anybody
who's not looking under the hood
influencer marketing is now a foundation
to to our society and that's a
monetization strategy that was very
difficult to comprehend for a lot of
people's back before it just got some
messes this up together
we've got some crappy business news
something bad all like you know good
old-fashioned business but quiet for
like 17 minutes until we change lives of
our trip or transform into Airport Gary
where did the disability got us this
cool stuff I'll tell you what's really
been obvious to me since crushes which
is that 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
thing it's everything when I tell you
everything like we're only going to be
so pretty
we're only going to be so funny we're
only going to be so charismatic we're
only going to be so talented in what we
do no question the variable of success
in the last decade as I became a poster
child of entrepreneurship and crushing
it and hustle the people that have out
worked the other people have succeeded
at a much higher variable and I'm sure
we'll hear about those stories when we
profile people that crushed it I
basically want to say something like
from October 7 2009 I don't know what's
nathan book came out until today I have
worked so hard so much more than I did
when I wrote crushes and it is and I've
been documenting it in my daily be blog
[Music]
a lack of patience that so many people
deployed against crush it was the reason
so many people sales if you're reading
this book and you started something in
2010 because crush it motivated you and
you failed my belief is that you didn't
put in enough work or you didn't do it
around your passion or you just weren't
talented enough but the one that you can
control the most was your work ethic and
when I audited people through the last
decade that hadn't succeeded they
weren't working as hard as it actually
takes 7:00 p.m. 2:00 in the morning is a
real conversation
you